mon carnet de bèze avait 155 non puisque
j'avais besoin de ce genre de choses
valais pour mieux que j'en fasse à un
petit bouquin pour savoir s'il voulait
les revoir ou pas j'en ai fait des
conneries dans ma vie bien j'en fais
encore mais bon ça donne du piment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'appelle jean lemonnier j'ai 81
chine et en 1939 la bonne saison a
débuté hier
donc c'était assez mouvementée et puis
ce que j'aime c'est les mots croisés
j'en fais bordel j'aime les oiseaux et
puis j'ai une collection de chouettes
il y en a qui sont dans des boîtes parce
qu'elles sont problème pour être montré
mais le des ressorts quand les gens qui
me les ont offert bien les cornichons
sedan les motos pour les cornichons à
deux pattes
j'aime écrire des cartes noël j'en ai
envoyé 99 cette année et parce que
j'aime le plus au monde ses voyages et
ses devis que pour ça je suis né dans un
village il y avait 300 habitants mons
connaissez tous
on s'engueulait tous et puis je voulais
voir le monde sait tout et puis comme je
voulais plus aller à l'école fallu que
je fasse quelque chose
puis comme je voulais plus rester à la
maison non plus parce que trente
disciplines mais comme tu envoyait tout
chez moi envoyé chez aussi
à partir de 1950 et quelque jusqu en ce
sens 14
je suis allé à montréal j'ai fait
l'irlande de faire pour un an après j'ai
fait le norvège l'angleterre la suède
tout s'arrange de lacunes et puis après
ça ben je suis allé à une nouvelle
calédonie et puis on s'est acheté une
vieille bagnole et on a fait le tour de
l'australie en veille bailleul avec un
chat qui s'appelait cinzano puis de là
bas on a traversé l'amc à nice dans la
turquie en abriteraient jusqu'à paris et
+20 je me trouve un peu chez moi partout
mais faut dire que je n'ai peur de rien
alors ça ça arrange les choses
si si ça m'emmerde je re rentrer dans le
tort alors puis maintenant on l'a mais
j'ai quand même une canne alors je suis
le débat depuis qu'il ya des gens qui
vont sur la lune je rêve d'y aller parce
que je suis jalouse alors je rêve
d'aller n'importe où on peut aller mais
faut avoir les moyens pour la l'humain
ses petits poings petit voyage et puis
j'ai plus le le sentiment de pouvoir me
trouver un mec assez riche province
offrir j'ai fait là une croix dessus
je ne me suis jamais compliqué la vie à
me dire mais c'est pas grave il devrait
vivre un truc comme ça
chacun mène sa vie à sa façon j'ai pas
de jugements portés
mais moi c'était dans mes du gène de
voyager que je pense
j'aurais dû être [ __ ] gigant de
cheria les tziganes les [ __ ] rue
je vais avoir 80 ans là dans quelques
mois et je ne sens pas mais 80 ans
tant que je peux voyager moins cher
aucun problème si je suis l'article de
la mort je crève pisé tous ces points
j'ai donné mon corps à la science
ils démarreront avec ça ils pourront pas
utiliser mon choix doit avoir une
cirrhose
il est comme mon coeur sera vont encore
on sait pas
je n'aime pas l'internet ça c'est très
évident mais bon il faut faire pour
faire vous pouvez vous partager
[Musique]